hello everybody hope the year are good I
know it's quite late sorry but I've been
really busy this week because I've been
trying to sell an apartment that I
bought as an investment last year and
finally today it's sold but yeah I've
been really busy talking to potential
buyers
negotiating ER checking the contracts
going to the notary Etc so yeah one
thing less to worry about is done and
now I can focus again in the chart so um
although tomorrow it's Sunday and I'm
posting the ual Bitcoin soon the update
and I'm going to have the things more
clear because I have 15 hours or 12
hours until then so that's a lot of
price action to to see I have time to
look at the data Etc so I'm going to be
able to post a projection of price let's
see if it plays out or not but hopefully
yes um and I will tell you what I think
is going to happen next week but I think
this video is quite important because I
can explain to you my reasoning what I'm
ining at the moment am I bullish am I
bearish uh do I have any concerns I do I
have one this long week here we're want
to talk about this one week for a while
that that Thursday was was crazy I mean
look at that price action a lot of
Traders got liquidated here you know
many short positions with this pump here
was very aggressive and of course mostly
all those Longs there okay and breakout
traders that were trading a breakout of
this level um so yeah Thursday I guess
it was a sad day for for many Traders
and the problem that I have is this long
week I think it's a huge imbalance
$6,000 it is
crazy a week of $6,000 is crazy in the
4our time frame or in the 1 hour time
frame because if you notice guys and if
we Mark the 50% level of this long week
we would mark it around here
93,00 700 or 800 and if we go to the one
time frame look at that it's the same
level the 50% now I'm going to put a be
high at 94
94,000 that's to play just to play safe
because it could get filed 45% is the
50% considering that it's a round number
we could see a bounce from so yeah I'm
sticking to 94,000 just to play safe
okay that's the minimum level now
at this moment at this instance Saturday
night I think that it's likely that we
fail this long week the 50% level at
least next week okay that's what I'm
thinking um the areas where price could
start to drop from towards that level I
have two areas on my mind and I'm going
to show you right now but I think it's
what to be easier to see in the daily
time frame and I want you to pay
attention here okay look at this candle
here from Thursday that red candle that
you can see a long week to the upside
and a long week to the downside now if
we Mark the 50% levels of both weeks the
one on the downside is marked and the
one to the
upside it's around there what I've
noticed that usually happens when we
have this type of candles with a Weg in
both sides is that first one Weg gets
filled at least the 50% although it can
be the 100% all the way between the 50%
to the 100%
that's possible okay so we could still
go higher but usually what we see is at
least the 50% level and then we see a
reaction from there to the other week of
the same candle so yeah uh based on this
I think it's very likely that next week
we could see 94,000 the 50% level of
this long week okay that's what I think
um again tomorrow on Sunday I'll be able
to post um a price projection based on
this but I want to talk about this cuz I
think it's quite important okay so
careful H taking any long if you are in
a spot you can be very relaxed because I
don't think there is any bearish signal
or any top signal as long as I'm
aware okay and in fact if you notice
here you can see some kind of trend on
here support So price is simply going up
climbing to the upside slowly but steady
okay that's not any top signal in my
opinion uh a top signal would be to see
a lot of weeks to the upside and price
not progressing any further okay because
that would mean that the market Mak is
opening shorts at the highest levels of
the chart and then is going to retrace
but you are not seeing that at all in
fact in the weekly time frame look at
these two weeks here you could argue
that there is um very fast buying
from these levels and that potentially
signal that price is going to continue
going higher um by the way if you notice
this week here from the red candle I've
talked about it and I said it was going
to get filled and it got filled the 100%
of it so Wick fill strategy works okay
it works in all the time frames in the
quickly time frame you've seen it there
and the next thing will be to see it
working in the 4our time frame with this
week and in the 1 hour time frame with
this same week so um yeah mainly I'll
tell you two areas where price could
drop towards the 50% level of this week
if I'm correct that's going to happen
next one level is this one the 50% it go
hit price retrace but you can see price
is trying to make another attempt
towards the level now usually when price
goes back to the 50% level of a week
let's go to the Daily time frame when
price goes back to the 50%
level then it tends to go towards the
100% level
okay and that would be towards there so
if price goes back to this yellow line
100 1,600 is very likely that price
continues going higher and goes to the
100% of the of the week in this case the
daily week now in the lower time frame
and that refers to this time frame it
would be very possible to see in that
case a sweep of the highs and then a
drop to 94,000 and I want you to pay
attention to this now okay it's very
important that price goes back to the
50% of this week that's
94,000 as soon as possible for the
simple reason that if price starts to go
up from here I'm not going to trust this
move because we have a huge imbalance to
downside that needs to get recovered so
that could tell me okay at any time
price is going to need to drop I don't
know that's around 20% from here okay
yeah 16% from the top so I would much
prefer that price drops to the 94,000
level a straight away if price do
something like this it could even do
even a sweep of this highs if price do
something like this
okay and drops to the 50% level it'll be
much better because then yes price can
continue going higher as as high as he
wants and I'm not going to uh be
thinking that that's a move that I
cannot trust that can be a very legit
move all right so that is what I'm
thinking F please the 50% level as soon
as possible Bitcoin so I think we've
covered all my ideas about this long
week the next thing would go um would be
ethereum now ethereum 4,000 level that's
the level we marked perfect look at that
support there and then it goes up okay
absolutely perfect price action
here um to be honest I was hoping to
catch ethereum a bit lower it was not
possible too strong guys it's way too
strong especially with the Bitcoin pair
and that means that if Bitcoin goes up
ethereum goes even higher okay so very
strong uh coin at the moment um just
broke
$4,000 psychological level um all I'm
thinking is that if he
continues getting an acceptance Above
This level about
$4,000 I would like to see to be honest
the daily 50 May catching up with price
a bit more then if you like to see
something like this okay A Move probably
between 5,000 to 5,500 I would probably
tell you 5,000 is the level I would mark
because it's another psychological level
okay so getting acceptance or even
ranging around
$4,000 would be very positive because if
you notice here what happens you get to
$4,000 price retraces you get to $4,000
price R races if we range here then that
means that price is going to continue
going higher and that the next Target
will be $55,000 now pay attention to
this resistance because if we go to the
Bitcoin dominance you're going to see
the same thing okay support resistance
right look what happen at resistance but
hits reject Heats reject again here
rejection now look what happened here we
range we do something different we range
here for quite a while and that tells me
price goes up to fill all these
inefficiencies all those candles those
liquidity pools price hit exactly the
last liquidity pool vat as we thought
and now it dumps that is price action
okay you'll see this all the time not
only with the Bitcoin dominance not only
with Bitcoin or ethereum you're going to
see this also in altcoins in the S&P in
Gold any Commodities you can imagine and
Forex per it happens everywhere okay we
can apply the same trading system to any
Market cuz everything works based on
human behavior and that a some change
now with the Bitcoin
dominance um yeah it's in a free full
from that level because he's done
already all the job to fill this
inefficiencies here so now he doesn't
have any reason to why should continue
going higher however we are here at the
weekly 5A and in the daily time frame
you're going to
notice that it's very V extended at the
moment it dropped too fast H which is is
it's nice for the AL and we like that
but it's true that it's likely that it
recovers
H some upside momentum okay also if you
see in the daily time frame I'm starting
to see weeks to the downside but price
not progressing any further that could
potentially signal that the trend is
going to change uh in the lower time
frame and that's why that I mark this
box here around 58% because I don't
think that that would be a very strong
resistance look at all the all the
consolidation that we have here open
interest is very high in this area which
US means a strong resistance also the
daily 50ma is going to start going
towards there so you want to get that
another resistance and then potentially
going lower so that's what I'm I'm
thinking I think that it's likely and
very possible that we see the bcoin
dominance um taking a breath to
58% or 57 to 3% I would probably tell
you that it's more likely that if we
move this box to the this area here that
will be more likely between 57 and
58% considering the trajectory of the
daily 50ma it would match around there
okay and then price should continue
going lower which is very good for Al
coins now what it means is that um it's
about timing right and it's something
that is not under control but what would
happen if the Bitcoin dominance goes up
towards that box there okay and during
this move Bitcoin is slowly bleeds
towards the 50% of the week that will be
uh quite bad for alins in the short term
because this is a very shortterm move
what I'm talking about but in the short
term if that aligns together and it
happens at the same time it means that
the aloh market would have a
considerable retrace not a maor retrice
I'm talking around maybe a 10% retrace
which would be perfectly healthy in fact
we've seen that um very recently a
couple of weeks ago go to the total
three guys don't going to see there any
of these retraces
here is pretty
much at 10% you see there
10% here it's even higher
13% okay but it's true that if those
things go at the same time which is that
the Bitcoin dominance goes up while
Bitcoin goes down then altcoins are
going to retrace consider
perhaps towards this level which if you
notice this Mia it's a bit overextended
and it will be nice if we can test the
support of the daily 50ma so who knows
it's possible that we have another
opportunity in Al coins and I laugh
because it keeps happening okay the ALCO
Market keeps giving us opportunities to
to get in um although it's true that we
should have got in on all positions
early in September October and we took
some entries it's never late because
it's possible that it do something like
this okay and this is the r you want to
get take advantage of if it happens
because you are following the trend to
the upside all right so um based on that
we're going to go into a couple of of
alims but not
many first of all Solana okay Solana if
you
notice I'm going to talk about two
potential trades
the current trade that I'm in for this
weekend is this I posted it on the
telegram on my telegram channel it's
free it's in the description feel free
to join and I post there quite often and
it's completely free what I'm thinking
is that it's likely that Solana is the
next one to pop up uh it could even be
this weekend now it's aturday night so
perhaps tomorrow on Sunday it's likely
that it reaches this level here at least
around 250 that's what I'm hoping for
retrace to the 4our 50 MAA okay you can
see how this area it's holding pretty
well although there is a few weeks below
it but overall I think that there is
possibility for upside momentum over the
weekend okay or early at the start of
next week especially if Bitcoin sweeps
those highs then yes s can can pull this
move pretty easily okay so that's the
trade that I'm currently in and then for
a a spot if we go to the Daily time
frame I was talking in my last video
about
210 because that would be pretty much
going to this previous
High okay and also testing the daily 50a
and we didn't get there by $54 okay we
went to 2 15 not to 210 so I couldn't
take that extra entry in my spot
position but still is possible okay if I
again if we see that Bitcoin dominance
low time frame move up and Bitcoin going
down in the short term and that happens
at the same time then Solan is still
going to give us the entry at the daily
50 right that's is still possible then
hopefully it continues going up but what
I say is that we should be prepared
for this scenarios too and that's why
even a bull market is good to have some
usds on the side some Stables because
there is always potential re-entries to
your already open trades or open
positions or spot bus okay um if we get
there that's what I'm adding H size to
my spot box so let's see if we get that
then another one is the
here that's another token that we've
been talking about that is consolidation
here at the lows you got them there soon
even and I do think that it's going to
eventually going to get there to $12
okay to this peot point so again I told
you I'm not selling any of my tokens now
it's possible that is is still going to
happen uh something like this even lower
the deviation below the EUR line test
the daily 50 Ma and that would happen if
we have the Bitcoin dominance going up
Bitcoin going down at the same time then
yes it's possible that we could still
see $7 in Tia if that happens no problem
we can reent that zone and then hope
that price should go to $112 in the next
few weeks all right so just giving you a
few ideas guys and then another token
that I've end
recently is is I think is this one I
didn't get the right
chart this one okay Destra I took an Ser
of 40 and I was lucky because in my
exchange it got trigger here a Ser of 41
so I go look at that but my point is
that again why couldn't we see a sharp
retrace to here it's possible okay if
that happens then re-entry cuz price
should go High okay and we can see this
with many different charts also another
entry that I took already
or um I saw this chart on on X well not
the chart but I saw the the token
getting named on X so I took this entry
but that's my risk management for my
trade but you can see here the
momentum okay you can see here this
scale of price it's heading to the
upside it feel like the down trend is
over we've been ranging but the same
time as making higher lows and higher
highs and price would eventually go back
to the highs all right so um again who
knows perhaps we have another re-entry
here okay it's possible these are the
things that you should be prepared of
and you can be taking you could take
some some Longs at the moment but be
also considering the idea that it's
possible that we see a little retrace
again okay and that's something of
course we should take advantage of so
that's pretty much everything guys let
me take my notes yeah I've mentioned
everything that I wanted to say guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon well I'll see I'll see you
tomorrow with the Bitcoin T update thank
you for watching